[Music]
[Applause]
Joe Thomas Cleveland browns offensive
lineman eight-time All-Pro 10-time pro
bowler and now a Hall of Famer we did it
Joe wait are you a Hall of Fame elect or
are you a Hall of Famer how does that
work since it's not official yet
that's true I think I'm merely an
elected Hall of Famer as of right now
and it's not official until this summer
do you have a jacket
uh just like a winter jacket
just fitted us no no they fitted us for
the gold jacket this weekend and then we
actually get the gold jacket at the gold
jacket dinner which is like the Friday
before the Hall of Fame game this summer
where are you right now
uh I am in Wisconsin at my farm and I
didn't know it was going to be video but
at the last minute I had to put a real
fire on in the back because I heard you
have a real fake fire yes I do in your
studio can you have a real fake fire
that's what you have no it's real fake
fire I think I just have a fake fire
no it's very fake yours is real yours is
mine's real real
okay tell the story about how you found
out and how your wife kept it a surprise
that you got into the Hall of Fame yeah
makes me a little nervous how good my
wife was at keeping a surprise for me
because I was sure that the announcement
whether you made it or not was going to
come close to the Super Bowl because
they weren't going to tell us weeks in
advance because of course in today's
social media World you'd think it would
leak but uh sure enough two weeks before
NFL honors there's a knock at my door
but we're all hanging out in the kitchen
and it's right after school and so I
hear a knock and I think that it's maybe
just the neighbor kids coming over to
play with my kids which happens all the
time and
um so my kids they bust around the
corner they go to the front door
thinking that their friends are going to
be there and they see Walter Jones in a
big gold jacket taking up both door
frames and I'm still sitting in the
kitchen with my wife and I hear the kids
like running back from the front door
into the kitchen dad there's a guy with
a coat at the door and then all of a
sudden my son he's like jumping four
feet in the air like a Mexican jumping
bean he goes Dad we made it
and we made it because I was just so
caught off guard in that moment I was
not expecting any announcement for at
least another week and so it took me a
second but then once I realized what
happened it was so awesome that first of
all my idol Walter Jones the guy kind of
emulated my own game after was the guy
that was at the door doing the knock but
for him to basically deliver the news to
my son and then to be my son the be the
one that delivers to me allows us to all
share in that memory in that moment and
I think that just made it as special as
it possibly could have been okay are you
leaving out a slight detail of what you
were wearing
or no or not wearing yeah there were
some details uh before the knock
happened because my wife told me we were
going to go out to dinner with the
neighbors uh Friday night no makes sense
and so I was just in my underwear just
around the house but she knew at four
o'clock the knock was gonna happen and
so she's like why don't you go upstairs
and get ready I'm like well we don't
have to leave for dinner for like 30
minutes it takes a man like five seconds
to get ready like I I can wait until
another 20 or 30 minutes he's like just
go upstairs and put your pants on
I'm like geez lady back off so I'm like
all right fine but you know like any
good husband I figured I should probably
go listen so I went upstairs and I did
put pants on at least for the official
knock at the door okay why are you in
your underwear
all day
I mean that's what you do when you
retire from the NFL right why would you
put clothes on if you don't have to
I like that she's trying to get you to
put your pants on because she knows
they're going to be a knock at the door
and you're going to be there in your
underwear where yeah Walter Jones is
there to tell you you're going in the
Hall of Fame yeah that would have been
uh very embarrassing for me had anybody
seen me in my underwear that's awesome
well congratulations
um all right a couple of things here uh
the condition of the field in the Super
Bowl
would you rather have grass or turf if
you're playing
so I've always been a grass guy two
reasons one it's easier on your body but
also as an offensive lineman we're the
biggest slowest guys in the field they
always say we're the last bus stop on
the roster like if you can't make it as
a lineman your next step is going to
coaching like there's no
help too if you get slower or less
athletic after being on the offensive
line and so when you play on a little
bit of a slick field it usually favors
the guys that are a little bit less
athletic not as quick because it kind of
neutralizes some of that quickness and
some of that speed so personally I like
grass I think it's better for the
players and it's better for us slow guys
but certainly those receivers those guys
that rely on Quick Cuts that rely on
trying to create power like your pass
rushers those guys hate it sometimes
because they can't get to some of the
technique that usually makes them the
great players that they are with their
quickness and their power how important
was that Kansas City offensive line
they were awesome I mean I kind of had a
feeling that things were going to come
down to line play but I thought it was
going to favor the Eagles right I
thought everybody looked at the Chiefs
and said you know their Line's pretty
good but this Eagles defensive line is
so good top to bottom and especially
looking at Andrew Wiley at right tackle
that was really a big mismatch going
into this game with Hassan Reddick but
you got to give him a ton of credit
because he played a fantastic game one
of his best games especially after not
playing all that well in the Super Bowl
a couple years ago yeah it just it's
embarrassing to have a field like that
that did affect some plays and it
certainly affected it felt like the
eagles more than the Kansas City Chiefs
how does that happen
how did we get to the Super Bowl and we
play on a field where there's question
marks about it
yeah it's so crazy I'm not exactly sure
I think maybe it has to do probably some
nerd out there would tell you that you
know because they grow the grass outside
in a different environment and then when
you bring it inside it changes like the
humidity level and it makes a little bit
of a do line on top of uh the grass and
that's probably why it makes it a little
bit slick but I totally made that up I
have no idea
but you're a farmer so it sounds like
you know right do you have a working
farm
I do yeah we're actually starting to uh
sell some beef to local restaurants we
we call it six Springs Hall of Fame beef
because it's better than Prime so you
can't just get this anywhere Dan you can
only get a finest establishments uh
known to man yeah maybe I'll send some
to you it's not pro bowl beef it's Hall
of Fame not merely Pro Bowl beef this is
Hall of Fame this is one step above Pro
Bowl beef anybody can get Pro Bowl beef
we're talking to Joe Thomas the uh newly
elected Hall of Famer Hall of Fame elect
I guess until you have the official
ceremony there I I was wondering about
this first battle Hall of Famer
would you be in favor of a different
jacket color any kind of designation
that says you're a first team or first
ballot Hall of Famer
I'm not personally because I feel like
the Hall of Fame team and the community
is all one it doesn't matter if you get
in on the first Ballot or the 20th
ballot like I I don't like
differentiating between the groups to me
I know there's been a lot of
conversation about hey there should be a
special wing for guys that are first
ballot and make them feel extra special
but just being a Hall of Famer for me is
what is special and I don't think
anything gets better than that great
there's an asterisk hey he made it on
his first ballot that's cool trust me
I'm very proud of that but at the same
time I don't feel like I should be an
elitist with a different color jacket
amongst the greats in the game also you
went to 10 Pro bowls now that that meant
something it doesn't mean that now when
you go to the Pro Bowl right and I'm
wondering is there a way to salvage
being named the Pro Bowl where just the
first team the guys who were initially
announced as that Pro Bowl team that's
it goes on your resume everybody else is
sort of like you know you're a
contributor to the pro you know Pro Bowl
weekend or like the slam dunk contest or
three-point shooting contest they're not
All-Stars but they're there for the
weekend because I don't I don't want the
designation to go away because it does
help guys resumes
yeah I would think that that should be
an easy change right the last thing you
want to do is just allow somebody who is
maybe the eighth person voted to the Pro
Bowl to be considered hey I made six Pro
bowls well actually you weren't elected
to any pro bowls but because of people
back like that Tyler Huntley threw two
more touchdowns than I did
right yeah I agree I mean I I think to
be a pro bowler you should be elected to
the Pro Bowl and and then maybe you
played in the Pro Bowl but otherwise
you're just watering down what it means
to be a pro bowler if you know you're
the seventh or eighth person that
actually gets elected on the first
ballot uh we all done questioning Jalen
hurts
I hope so I've been a fan of him for a
long time and I think his game is what
the NFL game is going to where you have
a quarterback who's a great passer but
also can hurt you with their legs and
can stretch the field sideline to
sideline it just puts defense in
Conflict constantly and I think the only
downside of those type of quarterbacks
is you do see him get injured more
because they take a lot more hits but
also you don't have to hold your block
as long with someone like Jalen hurts
I'm guessing well yeah absolutely but
also the other thing that's really
important is those Defenders they freeze
for about a half a second or a second on
almost every play because they don't
know if it's a run or a pass because a
lot of those RPO things they're trying
to figure out hey who's the person that
they're putting in Conflict who's the
person that they're reading and so it
really slows the defensive and all the
reads down explain to me Lane Johnson
how is that not movement
he's a magician I used to do that type
of stuff in my game you're going to try
to take care or take every Advantage you
possibly can to get ahead of the snap
count to do what you can to gain an edge
because those dudes across from you a
lot faster than you are yeah but it felt
like he was getting away was he getting
away with something
so you'd have to actually go back and
watch the coaches tape to be able to
watch right down the line of scrimmage
and to slow it down when that ball
starts to move because you can see like
hey he's moving first but as long as
that ball just starts to move when he
moves he's fine
I I'm watching it right here Kelsey's
not even snapping it yet
just a split second and Lane Johnson
Starts to go back to pass protect that's
perfect that's what I call Perfection
uh with no flag you have pants on today
just want to make sure uh I can't show
you that okay reveal that information
it's uh congratulations and I don't know
if you say to your wife to refer to you
as Hall of Famer like how does Hof The
Hop yeah I think I'm going to bring that
up on Valentine's Day hey by the way
honey from now on you need to refer to
me as Mr Hall of Famer
oh and I forgot your your Valentine's
President congratulations uh thanks for
joining us buddy my pleasure Joe Thomas
Hall of Famer yeah imagine that you're
sitting around your underwear and your
wife's like put pants on he's probably
going okay he's up here ah come on honey
come on you know I don't wear pants
around the house I'm a Hall of Famer